oh [ __ ] c'est hélas tu me sauver je
suis certain que tu m'emmènes avignon
quoi hier à la soirée je crois que j'ai
rencontré la fille la plus merveilleuse
du monde ça c'est quoi tes conneries
excuse moi qu'est ce tu fous là ah non
mais moi c'est parce que je suis un pote
de stéphanie en fait si tu pouvais de
barrettes à uzès finir la partie
ok si on part maintenant on y est
largement pour l'intérêt à vivre un
grand truc de ouf
une de nos plus belles aventures sur les
deux tu vas voir tu as un problème les
trous du cul sorte de pékin express mais
dans la nièvre quoi oui oui oui voilà on
va voir des gens formidables
la carte se lève le pouce est homosexuel
non
matt et moi ces put barys nous aussi
grinta parisse attendent enfin paris on
s'en fout c'est en des baisses on verra
après quand on va voir des paysages
fabuleux au sérieux patrice une boîte
pression ouais on aura besoin de rien
n'importe quoi il peut clamer couilles
c'est le cheval barres 2d comme on dit
mieux belle aventure cette fougue de la
jeunesse cette liberté [ __ ] mais tu
peux pas croire l'une des histoires je
sais pouvoir bavaisis timing croquer
matin bien sûr cattin a sûrement que ça
à [ __ ] j'y vais pour lui dire que je
les aime plus idiot est amour dieu et à
mandela mais tu m'as une capote